figuraient bon jour on en dirait que ce
jeudi après midi pour suivre le
décollage d'une fusée la diffuser news
shepherd la fusée de blue origin de jeff
bezos ce je suis aguerrie devant albert
rédacteur en chef du service science du
figaro bonjour cyril avec vous on va
parler bien évidemment de ce lancement
mais aussi de toute la thématique du
tourisme spatial puisque c'est de ça
dont il s'agit aujourd'hui on va vous
passez les images qui sont en train
d'être d'être filmé par les équipes le
décollage aura lieu dans le quinze
minutes on voit la capsule avec les
astronautes qui sont déjà à l'intérieur
on va parler un peu de ce qu'ils sont de
2 comment va se dérouler ce vol bien
évidemment tout cela et vous n'hésitez
pas à poser vos questions on essaiera
d'y répondre du mieux qu'on peut cyr et
déjà on peut être qu'on peut présenter
rapidement ce lancement comment il va se
dérouler alors c'est le sait le
lancement c'est le 20ème lancement de
cette de cette petite fusée et c'est la
première fusée qui est vraiment dédié
aujourd'hui au tourisme spatial et qui
on l'a vu lors des précédents vols a
emmené notamment jeff bezos le fondateur
de bleury jean qui est plus connu pour
avoir créé et amazon
il a investi n'est une grosse partie de
sa faute sa fortune on parle d'un
milliard da par an pendant plus de dix
ans pour faire marcher blue origin pour
réussir à mettre au point cette fusée
c'était compliqué c'est une base au
texas mais du désert on voyait un peu
sur l'arrière-plan dans les images
peut-être
et en fait ils ont beaucoup travaillé
dans le plus grand secret ils ont fait
plein de lancement
inquiétez pas qui était jamais quand
même en secret un peut pas lancer une
fusée mais sans prévenir avec peu de
publicité enfin c'est une méthode de
développement qui a été longue était
compliquée parce que c'est très
compliqué à mettre au point une fusée
est là aujourd'hui on a on a une on a
des touristes c'est vraiment des
personnes qui ont payé donc ça c'est
quand même une nouveauté incroyable on
est dans une phase de la conquête
spatiale ou des gens payent et prennent
bord avant prennent place à bord pardon
d'un vaisseau spatial là c'est une
capsule elle est au sommet de la fusée
la fusée elle s'appelle new shepard de
shepard en fait c'est un hommage direct
au premier astronaute américain qui a
été dans l'espace donc c'était chez
s'était séparé il ya une aussi de
nuances c'est le premier dans l'espace
mais c'était pas le premier américain en
orbite le premier américain david
c'était john glenn et la prochaine fusée
de blue origin qui est en train d'être
développé s'appelle news glenn et celle
là elle sera plus grosses plus puissante
elle ira jusqu en orbite dans la
différence c'est quoi parce qu' est-ce
qu'on va dans l'espace et c'est aller en
orbite dans l'espoir tout ça c'est pas
forcément la même chose on peut
peut-être parler de ça en fait là le le
vol on le voit la société sur les images
c'est un vol ce qu'on appelle suborbital
la fusée elle va monter jusqu'à ce
qu'une attitude un peu supérieures à
100km un endroit où il ya plus
l'atmosphère
c'est le vide et donc on considère que
c'est l'espace en fait y'a pas il n'y a
pas de frontières arbitraires entre
l'atmosphère et l'espace c'est pas
un moment on a en franchit une ligne en
et dans l'espace donc en fait c'est une
question de définition
on sait qu'au delà de 80 km il ya
presque plus dernier quelques atomes qui
connut de se balader et donc il ya une
discussion un peu sur ce que la
frontière c'est 80 100 km en fait c'est
pas très grave parce que cette capsule
elle va au delà de 100 km toute façon
dont elle est elle va au delà au delà
des deux frontières
accepter ce qui n'est pas le cas pour le
vaisseau de virgin wii dodon par louis
jariel curan ya donc voilà jean
galactique et là le cc brandson donc
c'est le patron britannique un peu qu'on
connaît pour ses excentricités ses
phrases qu'on peut dire frasques et là
il lui l'a fait un vaisseau qui est un
peu qu'un peu un problème performances
et qui arrivent pas aller au dessus de
80 km donc ils ont décidé d'envoyer des
astronautes à 70 mais les touristes en
fait au delà de 80 km et dire c'était
l'espace mais certains disent la cour de
la convention internationale ce qui est
100 km bon c'est un peu des disputes de
clocher qui ont pas beaucoup d'intérêt
l'idée quand même c'est que le vol il va
de courte durée oui ça y est c'est
quelques minutes d'apesanteur
c'est pas de la pesanteur parce qu on
est loin de la terre et qu'on ressent
plus la réaction ça c'est juste parce
qu'on dise où ils seront en chute libre
le moteur s'arrête au moteur ce couple
la capsule continuer à monter pendant un
moment elle arrive en août cette cloche
et elle redescend dans toute cette phase
là
les astros de houston en apesanteur à
l'intérieur mais ils sont à présenter un
peu comme si nous on est entre
l'ascenseur au 100e étage d'une tour et
que l'ascenseur tournoi est en chute
libre on se retrouve un a présenté la
même manière sa seule plus f que
l'ascenseur qu'il tombe mais certains
des parachutes cette fois ci allez-vous
vous avez pu le voir sur les images qui
étaient diffusées alors là on va rester
en direct parce que le lancement va va
bientôt avoir lieu de 10 minutes mais
les images que vous avez vu avant
c'était le cas lors pas le précédent
mais celui d'avant c'était un lancement
qui avait eu lui aussi puisque des
lancements s'était déjà on l'a dit le
20e et oui c'est le vingtième de la 2de
la petite fusée new shepard
mais il ya eu il ya déjà des lancements
avec des touristes donc c'est pas c'est
pas une première incroyable de ce côté
là
mais c'est aussi aussi pour montrer
qu'on est en train d'entrer dans une
phase vraiment de presque de routine de
cet exercice et c'est ça qui est pour
moi pour moi ce qui est le plus marquant
c'est ça c'est qu'en fait on a on a
abordé cette capsule cinq personnes qui
payent et 1
un chanceux qui est garé l'aïe qui est
lui un des premiers employés de glory
jean un des fondateurs de la société et
qui est le concepteur en gros de cette
fusée qu'on voit à l'écran qu'une forme
bizarre la forme bizarre c'est pour
laisser de la place dans la capsule on
voit que les hublots sont de grande
taille donc là l'intérêt c'est vraiment
laisser de la place aux spectacles pour
que les spectateurs les six personnes à
bord est bien de la vue donc chacun à sa
fenêtre c'est important une fois qu'ils
arrivent une fois que le moteur est
coupé ils se décrochent leur ceinture
mais là c'est la pesanteur ils peuvent
flotter dans la capsule où le volume et
on le voit à l'écran c'est pas si grand
que ça mais quand même il ya la place
pour parer à un soyouz dont a parlé mais
c'est ça change les choses c'est quand
même assez spacieux donc et tous ceux
qui ont sont revenus
10 quand même que le spectacle est
hallucinant enfin c'est le ciel de même
en plein jour le ciel est totalement
noir on voit les étoiles
la courbure de la terre est clairement
visible à l'horizon on voit un peu
légère couche un peu bleutée de
l'atmosphère ils sont au dessus de cette
couche qui protège la terre donc c'est
c'est quelque chose qui reste ils sont
peut-être pas en orbite autour de la
terre qui ont des vrais notre notre
comme thomas pesquet dans la station
internationale mais ça reste une
expérience hors du commun avec une
vision de la terre qui bat que rien
d'autre ne peut reproduire que cul voilà
qu'un décollages de fusées c'est un
ticket d'entrée vers vers le spatial on
commence à eau comme on l'a dit on
change un peu de paradigme on peut dire
on peut envoyer des ddd tourisme des
touristes dans l'espace de manière on
peut dire
comment appeler ça très
industrielle presque oui ça devient
industriel c'est à dire que c'est
davantage davantage probable origine
c'est que le développement a été long et
très coûteux on parle donc de plusieurs
milliards de dollars dont je vous laisse
le coude le calcul si on considère qu'on
paie le prix du billet est pas connue
mais si ça tourne autour de 200 mille
dollars ou moins de 100000 euros
ça fait 5 passes et qui paye par vol 1 1
million de dollars par vol avec un
milliard il faudrait 1000 vols pour
rembourser un investissement d'un
milliard dont on est encore très très
très très très loin d'une rentabilité
pour ce genre d'opération en revanche
pour blue origin pour la communication
c est pour bo c'est quand même un coup
de publicité fantastique et c'est aussi
un moyen de
huy de la fusée existe des installations
sont déjà été développés elles sont
construites donc de les remplir de
carburant avec de l'oxygène et
l'hydrogène c'est pas si compliqué que
ça et ça peut à partir ce moment-là
devenir une opération rentable mais sur
le long terme si on prend le coup
développement je pense qu'on en est
encore très très très très loin alors
sur les images qu'on a en direct on voit
que je pense que le compte à rebours
était bloqué à 9,5 en wallon n'a pas le
sombre ne pourra pas vous dire
exactement ce qui s'y passe peut-être
que si ils l'ont annoncé on va essayer
de comprendre
ce qui se passe mais là on a le premier
chronomètre du dessus qui est bloqué à 9
59 et un autre prendre être qui est en
train de défiler pour le temps en plus
en fait c'est quelque chose qui est pas
non plus
inhabituel geste sur les lancements
d'avoir des des retards comme cela non
en fait c'est très courant là une phase
qui est quand même assez importante et
qui sait pas lequel on joue pas que la
sécurité c'est le remplissage des
réservoirs on voit connecter à côté du
soutien des images on voit là une
radio qui est connecté donc c'est
l'heure c'est le remplissage des
réservoirs jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire
les carburants de l'oxygène liquide
et de l'hydrogène liquide qui sont
extrêmement froid et comme ils sont
quand même l'on refroidit mais on est à
l'air libre au texas ils finissent
toujours par se réchauffer une partie
des gaz donc il faut toujours rajouter
en continu du carburant c'est une
opération qui est complexe qu'il faut
potentiellement dangereuses parce que
les carburants ils sont en flammes c'est
ça qui fait qu'ils proposent la fusée et
donc c'est aussi pour ça que les les
les passagers sont vraiment à l'inter de
la capsule la porte est fermée
voilà il ya un système d'éjection en cas
de problème du remplissage tout et tout
est prévu mais met donc les moments où
le compte à rebours s'arrête ça peut
être une vérification pour un premier
remplissage ça peut être la météo avec
des vents en altitude qui sont trop
élevés parce que on l'a dit tout à
l'heure la capsule la décence ou
parachutes
des vents trop élevé c'est à dire un
décalage par rapport à la zone de tir et
la zone d'atterrissage elle est la fusée
se repose également alors ça concerne
pas les personnes mais part entre la
fusée et réutilisables et c'est là c'est
la force de blue origin c'est
la capsule se détache au sommet n'en
consommait la parabole et les passagers
montent dans l'espace et en revanche la
fusée elle se elle freine l eure vient
se poser sur le haut mais à côté du pas
de tir quelques minutes après décollage
donc son
c'est une opération qui a été loin
d'être facile
et que maintenant aujourd'hui
oui ignorer l'origine maîtrise
parfaitement parce que c'est
j'aimerais bien savoir là alors que la
cause du alors on retard est-ce qu'on
peut passer avec sur les sur les images
au grand écran avec le son je demande à
riyad avec nicky qui s'occupe de
réalités
[Musique]
oui donc on est on est en hollande comme
viens de dire la présentatrice comme
vous l'avez puantes et comme vous avez
pu l'entendre on va prendre vos
réactions dans les commentaires on
n'avale pas ou qui nous quitte et qui tu
me dis que d'argent gaspillé et de
pollution pour rien
c'est une remarque qui revient souvent
sur les sur les lancements d'autant plus
que là c'est un lancement pour des
touristes finalement l'argent gaspillé
c'est
c'est un jugement pincer
les
c'est vrai que les passagers à bord sont
tous très riche idée en tout c'était je
crois chef d'entreprise et/ou un gros
investisseurs ils ont fait fortune déjà
et il paie une somme qu'on imagine être
très élevé pour avoir le privilège de
faire d'être à bord
mais c'est pas de l'argent jeté par la
fenêtre ça fait ça fait vivre des gens
chez blue origin ça
ça on voit là s'il ya de l'emploi ça
je après la pollution pour le coup la
solution de blue origin c'est la moins
polluante c'est la fusée elle brûle de
l'hydrogène et de l'oxygène et quand on
brûle les deux qu'est ce que ça produit
ce produit de l'eau où je dis pas qu'il
ya de l'énergie qu'on pourrait produire
et servier qui servirent l'autre chose
c'est vrai mais pour le coup il n'y a
pas d' il n'y a pas de pollution au sens
le combustion des combustibles fossiles
qui serait polluants et qui réchauffe
frais que moi donc c'est pas
le bilan environnemental des vols de
touristes d'origine et pour le coup
on
va reprendre les clips novateurs essai
de meubler je crois de la bouche a
priori dogon on va reparler par-dessus
coach donc voilà on voit les pour les
images sont les images des tests moteurs
le moteur de la fusée où il est il est
considéré certains spécialistes comme un
des
les plus abouties et les plus
techniquement
réussie en fait du secteur ne s'est pas
passé un vrai compliment
moteur qui terrifie casque est compact
et léger une qualité qu'on recherche
spatiale
et puis les frères vérifiable il a déjà
fait pas mal de vols avec sa chaîne pas
de panne connu au monde donc
c'est beau succès technique origines et
le fait qu'ils emportent des touristes
maintenant avec l'agrément de la
fédération
les autorités américaines qui ont charge
de la sécurité des vols aériens
ça prend aussi qu'ils ont un niveau de
sûreté
qui considérait comme commis comme très
très bon il ya une vraie concurrence en
faisant entre tous les tous entre les
milliardaires américains on peut le dire
on a on doit bien sûr elon musk richard
branson avec virgin il ya il ya une
vraie guerre on peut dire spatiale entre
ces d'entre ces grandes fortunes c'est
en tout cas il y en a qu un peu à
l'écart donc de brandson avec virgin
galactic et
huile a vraiment tout misé sur le
tourisme spatial
jeff bezos ce et elon musk le il voit
beaucoup plus loin il vole il veut aller
en orbite qui veulent avoir diffusé
géante complètement réutilisable qui
casse le coût d'accès à l'espacé qu'ils
changent jamais rien dans ton dont on
utilise le spatial aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'a déjà un peu fait le losc avec sa
fusée falcon 9 qui mon premier étage et
contenants réutilisables c'est vrai
chamboulement qui interroge tout le
monde dans le secteur les américains les
européens les chinois les russes au
monde au regard de sa saison mais
comment voit on va faire comment on est
obligé ce qu'on a envie de copier et et
et pour blue origin pour jeff bezos le
patron d'amazon c'est aussi il veut il
veut vraiment aller plus loin il veut
que le que l'espace devienne pas ce
qu'on appelle la nouvelle frontière
c'est un peu le smic américain
voilà de la conquête de l'ouest et
maintenant c'est à vous voir voix sur la
lune puis sur mars plutôt plus loin et
avec des intérêts économiques qui sont
très clairement identifiés
déjà les à court terme s'est élancé des
milliers de satellites en orbite autour
de la terre pour changer manière dont on
fait les télécommunications c'est
l'internet par l'espace c'est l'internet
haut débit par satellite c'est ce que
fait déjà elon musk avec starlink
starling c'est le débit aussi rapide que
la fibre avec une petite antenne 50 cm
il faut mettre sur un balcon donc
partout sur la planète donc c'est et ça
marche ça marche plutôt pas mal
donc mais ça demande des milliers de
satellites milliers de l'aimer et alors
qu'on fait depuis depuis les débuts de
la conquête spatiale depuis le premier
secours du nou camp 57 je crois qu'on a
lancé quelque chose comme six mille
satellite le ring dans l'espace il a à
la fois bezos elon musk qui vont chacun
lancé les constellations de plusieurs
millier de satellites donc on change
d'échelle et pour ça il faut des vrais
chiens et fusées réutilisables parce que
diffuser classé du type ariane elles
soient efficaces elles sont fiables
excellent 6,2 passes contexte des
éléments qu'on jette à chaque lancement
est-ce qu'il ya la place pour tous ces
satellites dans l'espace alors ça c'est
un train un gros gros gros débat parce
que quand on augmente le nom nous est
vite et surtout en orbite basse donc
proche c'est autour de 800 kilos entre
400 à 800 kilomètres d'altitude
oui on peut se dire que ça va être
encombré après
je sais qu'on a du mal à visualiser mais
l'espace est très grand
donc aujourd'hui quand on a dit qu'on
parle de rapprochement entre les
satellites et avec des risques de
collision on dit attention ouhlala il a
deux satellites qui sont passés tout
près l'un de l'autre en fait il était à
plus d'un kilomètre
donc je ne sais pas si vous imaginez un
kilomètre de vide
entre deux objets qui font chacun à m de
large là c'est en fait il la place il ya
beaucoup de place et l'enjeu c'est de
connaître avec précision les
trajectoires des satellites pour être
sûr qu'ils vont pas aller percuter le
voisin est ce assez c'est quelque chose
qui est en train de changer avec
notamment des acteurs européens comme
airbus qui se met à faire des nouveaux
systèmes pour être capable de mieux
connaître la position des satellites qui
sont déjà lancés et éviter les risques
de collision c'est plus une question de
gestion de flotte je dirais en tout cas
un moyen moyen terme
que qu'un vrai problème de place
l'espace est ce que ça peut changer avec
une collision 1 est-ce qu'on peut
nettoyer l'espace on va proposer de
bourdin oui oui il y aller il ya des
vrais programmes pour ça mais là elle
est donc techniquement c'est possible on
peut envoyer les satellites pour aller
attraper d'autres satellites qui sont en
fin de vie qui sont plus contrôlés et
qui risquent de devenir des
débris et des en tout cas des risques de
collisions avec d'autres satellites donc
ça on sait faire de la question qui a ça
résoudrait pas simple c'est qui va payer
parce que selon ses termes et avec des
fusées mon cher c'est que ça reste
quelque chose de compliqué de chair dans
qui paye et il ya notamment via un
programme européen qui est très
ambitieux
et qui était un appel d'offres pour dire
et qu'est ce que vous proposez un appel
d'offres pour les 1/2 finales qu'est ce
que vous proposez pour aller
chercher un satellite européen depuis de
bytom c'etait un un monstre à sa visite
d'observation de la terre qui a été
lancé et qui est maintenant qui est en
panne donc et à 800 kilomètres
d'altitude il est énorme et s'il ya un
moins de collisions a exclu la saf et
des milliers de débris ça pourrait être
un vrai problème pour le
season but là donc il ya des yade et il
ya les vraies études pour aller où elle
a nettoyé de spécial mais les nordiques
mais ça ne pourra pas pas ça ne pourra
pas te fais des petits débris on
pourrait parler avoir défilé pour les
chercher des briques quelques centimes
quand on lui connaît satellites sont en
sont en fin de vie est ce que l'on pose
dire qu'il est ce qu'il tombe de même
vers la terre alors en fait ils t'ont
ils tombent vers la terre
mais à des vitesses qui sont très très
très très variable selon l'altitude en
fait on a dit tout à l'heure il n'y a
pas de limite franche entre l'atmosphère
et l'espace donc même à 800 kilomètres
il reste encore de temps en temps
quelques heures quelques molécules de
gaz hotte de l'hydrogène d'oxygène et
qui vont frapper les satellites et donc
ils vont les ralentir et quand on
ralentit quelque chose en orbite et bien
sa vitesse baisse et c'est assez
évident est en fait et fini par réussir
qui finit par redescendre en orbite des
sens et quand ils descendent sa tête il
se rend dans une atmosphère de plus en
plus dense qui le ralentit de plus en
plus et jusqu'à jusqu'à l'embrasement
dans les couches de l'atmosphère comme
ça qu'un satellite fini sa vie mais
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est de dire
d'avoir des règles assez strictes pour
dire qu'un satellite on ne laisse pas en
orbite jusqu'à ce qu'ils tombent en
panne mais plutôt on dit on il a une
durée une mission qui est défini à
l'avancé au bout de cette mission est
bien le son opérateur prend l'engagement
de les redescendre pour le désorbiter de
manière propre et contrôler parce que
s'il n'y a pas des bonnes pratiques
donc c'est l'enjeu c'est plus il est
plus de ce côté là du côté des règles et
la législation c'est compliqué parce que
c'est un secteur international mais il
ya des accords qui ont été pris par les
différents acteurs du spécial notamment
pour éviter que les dernier étage de
fusée explosent pendant les années on a
lancées les fusées et les derniers
étages qui envoyait le satellite en
orbite il reste est lui-même en orbite
mais c'est du gros élément de fusées et
des états je dirais à voir certains des
réservoirs en fait
il restait un petit peu de gaz et ils
finissent par exploser ça crée des 10
des débris qu'on essaie de traque de
suivre aujourd'hui et qui peuvent faire
des problèmes pour pour d'autres
satellites donc dans des bonnes
pratiques c'est de dire quand on envoie
quelque chose dans l'espace et qu'on
utilise plus soit on le désormais de
manière active c'est ce que je fais rien
pour rien si cela consistait la
conception on s'est dit il faut que la
fusée son dernier étage soit capable de
redescendre dans l'atmosphère pour pas
rester un débris et papou de leur vie
mais tous les opérateurs tous les coups
tordus fusent elles ne sont pas
ce qu'il en est par exemple l'ex p 6
on va juste écouter ce qui est en train
de se dire sur le plateau
[Musique]
m
juste
en
[Musique]
train d'écouter en ce moment on essayé
de chercher les informations va à vrai
dire pour savoir ce qui se passe sur ce
lancement cyril bay on le disait alors
que normalement c'est une information
qui est assez communiqué là ce n'est pas
le cas a priori en fait on n'a pas
d'info ce double origine sur la raison
du
dollar est du coup tu la chronométrie
l'arrêt du compte à rebours on voit
qu'il est bloqué sur 9 59
ça fait déjà maintenant 20 minutes
devrait déjà dans l'espace race qu'ils
étaient partis à l'heure il serait même
revenue il serait revenu
donc on n'a pas trop d'infos est ce que
ça peut être plusieurs paramètres ça
peut être lié au remplissage des
réservoirs ça peut être un problème
électronique sur le contrôle de la fusée
ça peut être juste la météo avec il ya
eu des vols a été déjà reporté à deux
reprises parce que à cause de vent trop
trop fort en altitude
donc voilà on peut continuer à répondre
à vos questions laden qui vous demande
parce qu'on parlait tout à l'heure de la
lune de mars il dit au delà de mars
n'est simplement pas envisageable dans
les trois cent prochaines années sauf à
fracasser la physique pour contourner
ces lois
alors au delà de mars peut-être même
fayyad et il ya des lunes de jupiter et
saturne mais elles sont
elles sont loin mais c'est encore c'est
encore accessible avec des avec si on
est prêt que c'était des mois de voyage
après oui c'est vrai qu'au delà pour
sortir du système solaire jamais déjà
mars on n'est pas un mais
déjà la lune il faudra y retourner
fournier pas non plus grave une voie là
on y parthenay puis soit 172 dernier
donc c'était dernière mission apollo
apollo 18 qui est qui et qui voit là
mais on a et on n'a personne depuis donc
c'est très compliqué mars et par rapport
à la lune c'est c'est un souk est
incroyablement difficile le pour aller
sur la lune il faut trois jours de
voyage pour mars c'est au minimum 6 mois
ou alors trois mois avec vraiment et de
la marche de performance une fusée bien
même bien costaud mais entre 3 mois et 3
jours on comprend que l'enjeu est pas le
même il ya
voilà le retour est très compliqué parce
que les orbites de mars et la terre font
qu'il ya des créneaux
favorable et un voyage rapide qui se
produisent tous les deux ans donc si on
part sur mars six mois de voyage un an
et demi sur place après on a fait des
voyages très long ça fait des des
inconnus sur la sûreté attention de
pouvoir repartir voilà ça c'est vraiment
vraiment aller sur mars moi je
n'empêche j'ai l'impression que tout
tous les 20 ans dit on y sera dans vingt
ans et bien aujourd'hui on dit que ben
on y sera la nasa elle et les plans
c'est peut-être dans 20 ans
c'est compliqué de savoir de l'udc est
de savoir de faire la prospective et
qu'il a une l'élément le plus crédible
qui est en train de bouleverser ça c'est
ce que fait le musk lui aussi au texas
avec avec son vaisseau starship les
vaisseaux starship qui complètement
utilisable pour envoyer des astronautes
il a gagné l'appel d'offres pour aller
poser les astronautes de la nasa / main
sur l'argent avec le programme artemis
donc ça devient crédible en attend tous
avec impatience que le premier vol
orbital donc le premier vol avec
capacité de faire le tour de la terre
avec ce vaisseau au cours de l'année
peut-être avant la fin d'année les noces
disait il ya quelques mois disait début
2022 on voit que là il n'a pas les
autorisations réglementaires pour le
faire mais le travail avance donc ça se
fait sous là il est crédible pour aller
sur mars il va lancer un changement
d'échelle et les capacités qui rend
crédible un vaisseau et une fusée
capable d'envoyer des astronautes vers
l'iss
mais les les difficultés à lever sont
tellement nombreuses que je suis pas sûr
que ça va se faire tout de suite enfin
il braille d'une accélération de du
spatial grâce à ces acteurs privés
finalement jamais complètement
complètement on a vu en fait on l'a vu
[Musique]
ça fait maintenant dix ans que la nasa
arrêter ces lancements de navettes
spatiales
et elle était trop dangereuse trop cher
être dangereuse et est en fait
aujourd'hui le programme succès que
successeur de cette navette c'est la
fusée lourdes sls qui doit aussi être
prévues par les astronautes vers la lune
pas les poser sur la lune mais vers la
lune sa fusée géante qui est pourtant
construite avec des éléments la navette
spatiale les éléments qui ont déjà volé
eh ben il est chaud elle elle aussi ce
son pas de tir en floride elle n'a pas
encore volé ça fait 10 ans et elle à
présent a toujours pas envie d'asseoir
donc s'il n'avait pas eu le lots de
masques et le privé avec ces fusées
falcone s'est capsule dragon est bas les
américains il serait toujours très très
embêté il serait dépendant des russes
pour envoyer leurs astronautes dans la
station internationale j'ai eu un coup
d'accélérateur incroyable donnée par
elon musk il a
pas encore cassé le marché parce que ces
fusées reste assez cher c'est qu'on me
séparant afin le le business n'est pas
encore rentable a priori les 6,6 pour
enfin trouver le mot ce qu'il est il et
on pense très rentable et qu'il a un peu
augmenté ses prix et donc ils ans contre
elle comme neuf donc c'est ce qui vous
permet si vous voulez près de le payer
envoyé 22 tonnes en orbite basse ou
ses 8 francs géostationnaire dont pour
les grosses et des télécoms ces 67
millions de dollars
pour la même même type de missions
ariane 5 c'était le double
et on pense quand on pense qu'on n'a pas
les chiffres exacts mais on pense que le
losc maintient ses prix élevé
c'est-à-dire à 67 millions de dollars
parce qu'il a besoin de financer ses
projets en interne qui sont le
développement de sa fusée starship qui
écoutent affreusement cher c'est
gigantesque c'est une fusée qui sera
plus grosse que la fusée lunaire de la
nasa dans les années 60 et et aussi il
doit financer sa constellation starlink
avec des milliers de 7,6 oui on en parle
et c'est ce système qui permet d'avoir
internet par totalement mais le rate les
satellites internet à haut débit partout
dans le monde très haut débit c'est la
vitesse de la fibre avec du satellite on
est une question de jeanne demande
quelles sont les différences notables
entre la fusée de jay z et celle des
jeunes basques sachant que jeunesse qui
n'a pas qu'une seule alors oui oui elon
musk il a plusieurs fusées dans son
catalogue il y là il a une fusée qui est
vraiment opérationnels et qui fait la
majorité des vols aujourd'hui ses falcon
9 c'est une fusée puissante que la
catégorie dont gara d'ariane 5 est
capable d'envoyer les gros satellites
comme des petits des petits paragraphes
de quelques dizaines
celle là elle est le premier étage le
bas de la fusée totalement réutilisables
seuil était le premier à réussir ça
ce qu'on voit à l'écran avec blue origin
c'est une fusée qui fait dix-huit mètres
de haut qui est beaucoup plus petit
beaucoup moins puissante qui atteint une
vitesse d'une vitesse maximum fait la
glace et qui n'est pas capable d'aller
en orbite qui n'est pas capable
d'envoyer ni une charge ni un astronaute
autour de la terre elle fait juste des
petits petits vins petit pas son pareil
mais d'aider des sauts de puce à 100 km
d'altitude et l'euro descend tout de
suite pour aller en orbite il faut
atteindre des vitesses qui sont
considérables
dit sortir de la traction tenait faut
sortir l'attraction terrestre il faut
accélérer tellement tellement fort
j'ai plus les chiffres exacts en tête
mais je crois que la fusée la blue
origin va à 3000 kilomètres heures
maximum en vitesse de pointe pourrait
pour aller en orbite une fois les dix
fois plus vite il faut aller à 30000 km
heure au minimum et donc ça demande des
fusées beaucoup plus lourdes beaucoup
plus complexe et donc il ya il ya une
gamme gains de performances entre ce que
fait blue origin aujourd'hui elon musk
mais à la fois bleury jean donc à la
fois véloce et meuse qui travaille déjà
sur des futures ils sont vraiment
concurrence au programme de fusée géante
qui s'appelle news glenn pour blue
origin en hommage à la john glenn le
premier astronaute américain en orbite
la position de shepard le new shepard
qui lui était fait aussi un bond de plus
en réponse au rôle des soviétiques et
lone wolf sa fusée géante donc on en a
parlé c'est c'est le vaisseau starship
avec ce qu'il appelle son
buzz booster me booster voilà on vous
rappelle que le lancement qui devait
avoir lieu à 15h10 et retarder le
compteur s'est bloqué à 10 minutes
depuis 27 buts vous pouvez voir les
minutes qui défilent en haut à droite on
essaie d'avoir informations mais a
priori la de ce que nous savons
effectivement la société blue origin de
jalios n'a pas
communiqué sur les raisons de ce retard
on peut quand même rappeler que décoller
refusé c'est pas non plus comme prendre
la voiture ou prendre l'avion c'est un
peu plus dangereux
oui c est que c'est extrêmement complexe
et le fait qu'on arrive à voir
aujourd'hui un vol avec des touristes
payant et que c'est presque maintenant
de la routine enfin on voit que c'est
pas la routine parce qu'il ya quand même
un arrêt du compte à rebours donc il ya
une raison de sécurité
peut-être y aller mais le jeu on s'est
peut-être lié à la météo peut être lié
aux
au vaisseau lui-même à la capsule ça
peut être les systèmes de vie la capsule
il faut
il faut aimer
deux qu'on sait pas mais le
convoi en iran au delà du lanceur il
fait il fait presque vingt mètres de
haut s'est remplie de d'oxygène liquide
l'hydrogène liquide vraiment et on
met les rayons bel ensemble
ensemble dans la chambre de combustion
et on veut que la combustion soit
contrôlée pour propulser ses deux fusées
dans l'espace donc c'est c'est toujours
un moteur fusée s'est jamais quelque
chose de ce je pense que sa part en
jamais quelque chose de de routine
d'allumer un moteur de fusée c'est pas
anodin c'est pas anodin c'est pas quand
on met à tourner la quête sa voiture et
qu'on met un peu de décence dans le
moteur avec le nous on prend l'oxygène
de l'air ambiant pour faire brûler nos
l'essence de nos maux de nos voitures là
et là il faut que ça soit de l'oxygène
liquide elle avait renvoyé avec des
pompes sous très haute pression c'est
c'est
eh voilà et on en connaît il ya eu pas
mal de drame dans l'est dans la conquête
spatiale parce que ces moteurs et bien
de temps en temps les explose
le moteur d'origine il est très fiable
et il a l'air vraiment très bien conçu
et très réussi en tout cas ce que disent
les spécialistes qu'on interroge sur le
sujet mais c'est ça ne sera jamais là
quelque chose de routine donc à des
systèmes de sécurité à bord des capsules
qui sont des rétrofusées qui sont là
pour en vendre et la capsule l'éloigner
du de la fusée en cas de problème et
donc on est donc ils pensaient qu'ils
portent des combinaisons ignifugées dans
la capsule que voilà c'est
ça beau être un tour pour dire c'est un
tour de manège pour ultra milliardaire
oui il m'a très riche mais ça reste
quelque chose de risqué et qui sort de
l'ordinaire qui je pense ne sera jamais
de la routine en fait on a justement
natacha barrage qui nous dit il y aura
des gens dedans oui il ya six personnes
qui sont actuellement à l'intérieur de
la fusée sur la capsule un peu au dessus
comme vous pouvez enfin vous voyez cette
partie haute de la delà de l'affiché
dans lequel il y a six personnes une
capsule qui est assez spacieuse on l'a
dit par rapport à des années soyouz est
ce que justement l'on parle de tourisme
spatial avec mais est-ce que les
historiques par exemple est ce que est
ce que les russes ils peuvent envoyer
eux aussi grâce à soyouz des touristes
spatiaux oui et oui les russes l'ont
déjà fait et le coût du siège est pas le
même là pour on n'a pas les tarifs
exacts d'origine
mais il aimait les estimations qu'il ya
que ce soit pour bhl origin ou pour
virgin galactic de branson s'est entre
autres c'est au tour de deux cent mille
dollars on parle par passagers par vol
un siège dans un soyouz
c'est plutôt de l'ordre de 20 millions
de dollars
donc la mission d'au moins plusieurs
jours parce qu'on monte dans la station
spatiale internationale et on redescend
après mai donc c'est pas du tout la même
et la place à bord de soyouz els et l
est pas c'est pas innocent sin capsule
qui prend que 3 personnes et donc si on
veut faire un voile avec des touristes à
dire qu'il ya un instrument
professionnel et deux passagers
voilà mes donc ça reste un soyouz c'est
ça a été le premier véhicule qui est
utilisé par un touriste spatial c'était
dans les années 90 un riche milliardaire
américain qui avait très envie d'aller
en espace il a payé les russes et il est
parti gradis tito il est parti il a fait
son tour grâce à sa honda horizon qui
nous dit on vient de rapprocher la
passerelle de la capsule est ce qu'une
évacuation est en cours alors
effectivement la passerelle avait été
enlevé on peut être mettre le son
on va encore
avoir des informations puisque là pour
l'instant ils essayent de passer
d'autres d'autres contenus qu'il est
qu'il est qu'ils avaient en stock dont
le lancement est toujours prévu voilà on
a eu un lancement est toujours prévu et
là le fait que la passerelle se
rapproche de la capsule ça pourrait être
mon plein de raisons jeu nettement je
sais pas du tout mais là on voit que la
capsule en tout cas est toujours fermé
donc il n'ya pas de paix pas de
l'agression on le disait aussi c'est
quelque chose qui est assez courant il
fait assez courant qui arrive en tout
cas que c'est que ces lancements soit
soit retardé alors là on voit le
lancement qui dès qu'ils datent d'assas
et le précédent lancement j'ai justement
qui a été fait pour qu'on vous montre un
peu ce qui se passe mais vous inquiétez
pas dès qu'il se passera en direct on
vous fera bien évidemment
le oui la question que j'avais c'est
alors j'ai pu j'ai perdu le fil désolé
j'ai perdu qu avec tous ces images
différentes on va refaire la question de
jeanne d'arc alors à la place qui
engloutit nous demandent où en sont les
chinois dans le développement des
nouvelles fusées ce qu'il y à des
acteurs privés par exemple de leur côté
oui il ya plein de il ya pas mal de
start-up chinoises qui sont en train
si je veut schématiser qui sont en train
de copier les design de le spécifier
d'elon musk avec des fusils
réutilisables
ils ont des projets qui sont pour
certains qui sont déjà avancés avec des
moteurs qui ont tourné au banc on a vu
des acteurs privés chinois qui ont
réussi à faire décoller et diffuser les
faire se reposer de manière contrôlée
donc à une effervescence dans une zone
de ce niveau là mais le gros de l'effort
il reste gouvernementale
cesser le programme
habité chinois qui est considérable qui
est pas très rapide ce nom parle pas
beaucoup mais qui a progressé en fait
ils ont déjà une station en orbite qui
est bien plus petite que la station
spatiale internationale mais il ya des
astronautes chinois à bord ils font de
la science ils font des expériences
scientifiques
ils ont fait des îles à quelques mois
leur première sortie en scaphandre en
dehors de la station donc cédé des
avancées qui sont importantes c'est qui
qui montre que ben ils s'endorment pas
élan et leur objectif d'aller sur la
lune avant 2030 il est il est tout à
fait crédible donc il ya du privé qui
travaillent sur des lanceurs en général
de petite taille et concurrents qu'ils
espèrent de del bosque du réutilisables
mais le gros de l'effort et les
gouvernementale avec
ils font des dizaines de lancements par
an dont qui lancent beaucoup de
satellites pour les télécommunications
l'observation de la terre ils sont en
avance sur le reste du monde dans des
domaines comme la communication
quantique ils ont déjà un satellite qui
permet de faire des liaisons radio
sécurisé par
cryptographie quantique sfac une voie là
il donc ils ont ils ont des technologies
qui sont en train dans certains domaines
qui rattrape pas ce que fait l'occident
et tant d'autres sont déjà un peu en
avance et cet effort chinois il est il
il est il est persistant il est pas très
spectaculaire parce que c'est assez lent
et qu' ils font pas des dizaines de
lancement ni les images aussi belles que
celles de spe 6 et c'est là la grande la
grande mode entre guillemets de kout sp6
le visage c'est que l'on voit c'est
cesser de la production audiovisuelle de
très grande qualité prix est qu'il l'ait
qu'il qu'ils offrent pour les lancements
oui en fait il ya eu il ya eu de ce côté
là un énorme progrès par ses dépenses
ces boîtes privées qui ont brun qui bien
compris que chaque lancement était
l'occasion de faire parler d'elle et que
de mettre des on voit les vues embarquer
sont les fusées l'heure de décollage de
faire des
voyages et des environs organise t des
diffusions avec des vrais plateau avec
des commentateurs ils ont des très
belles images parce qu'ils ont les
moyens
importants notamment pour les caméras de
suivi quand qu'on trouve que tu s'agit
de suivre la la fusée au décollage une
fois qu'elle s'éloigne pas de tir il va
on imagine qu'il faut des grosses
grosses caméras avec ses angoisses et
des télescopes qui sont qui sont pointés
avec des moyens de suivi assez
performant pour suivre la vitesse de la
physique qui monte à deux vitesses y
avoir une image la plus nette possible
donc des gros moyens et c'est vrai
les opérateurs les autres l'enveloppé
retour de lancement que ce soir yann où
les américains ont dû un peu se mettre à
la page et suivre sa et rajouter des
caméras sur leurs lanceurs pour donner
enfin et on l'a vu d'ailleurs ça a été
très très réussie par ariane quand ils
ont lancé le grand télescope web de la
nasa
c'était le lancement le peut-être le
plus important jamais pour ariane parce
que c'est un télescope qui coûtait 10
milliards de dollars à l'agencé spatiale
européenne dame américaine et qui a été
lancé par ariane 5 en guyane et une
stèle lancement il fallait pas le rater
hélas pour le lancement on a eu des
images magnifiques on a vu le satellite
se détacher et s'éloigner sur son de
globes terrestres donc les images qu'on
aurait rêvé qu'on n'avait pas par le
passé avait quand même victime alors que
nous sommes en retour en plateau avec
les deux présentateurs
at elle déjà des couleurs de natascha
n'a pas dit qu'elle n'a pas décollé elle
a 37 ans de retard le d'école à 37 min
de retard pour l'instant on va pas
rester on va rester en direct bien
évidemment pour vous faire suivre par
contre je pense que je vais libérer
cyril et qu'il ya quand même en tant qu'
en tant que rédacteur en chef du figaro
science sûrement quand même des pales de
travail on peut pas le mobiliser comme
ça en tout cas merci beaucoup c'est
qu'il savait ça que c'est frustrant ne
pas savoir pourquoi les vilains avec le
compte à rebours on va essayer de suivre
ici est un roman on aura on donnera là
on donnera réponse j'ai peut-être une
petite dernière question
internautes qui demandait tout à l'heure
comment est-ce que c est ce que ces
lancements on peut dire que ça fait
avancer la science
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui non non
franchement ça fait pas avancer la
science
ça fait ça fait avancer les opérations
de blue origin donc pour eux c'est un
peu des répétitions pour les lancements
futurs de leurs fusées lourdes fusée
géante news glenn pour le reste non en
fait on
on fait un petit saut de puce à 100 km
d'altitude les passagers vont pouvoir
flotter voir la terre ils vont ils
auront un spectacle magnifique chance
j'en doute pas facile à l'école
aujourd'hui mais pour la science non ça
fait ça fait pas avancer grand chose va
fuser les déjà au point elle a déjà volé
c'est le 20ème vol il n'y a pas beaucoup
de surprises et on n'apprendra rien à
côté scientifique là dessus aujourd'hui
oui donc effectivement c'est ce
lancement qui retardaient pour l'instant
de 40 minutes qui peut avoir lieu à tout
moment ils peuvent redémarrer ce compte
à rebours en tout cas merci cyril
d'avoir été avec nous devons vraiment
nous on va continuer avec avec les
images en grand sans le plateau je vous
dis merci n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
alors déjà coutumier dessus soleil
puisque si ça décolle vous le verrez en
direct bien évidemment c'est toujours
très impressionnant à décollages de
fusées et bien évidemment mais n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner sur le sur le site du
figaro bien évidemment et sur la chaîne
youtube pour suivre tous nos lives et on
vous dit à bientôt pour d'autres lives
sur figaro live et on vous laisse avec
les images de blue rigide
c
[Musique]
en fait
si
et moi plus
[Musique]
sauf moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
nommé le monde débarque comme initiateur
cause
tim allen lane et john drake paille pour
le manager to one
[Musique]
et au-delà
je me dis là
et après
[Musique]
dabi
chanter l'amour reach mélange en carafe
stay tuned
nico
buteur
bakou
ouais
[Musique]
m
todd stern chef le royaume batch warning
croira bouffi of engineering croire
[Musique]
caldera cross systems et cabin fever
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
franchement
tous
[Musique]